ó ó já fiz um exercício de rir eu fui
correr um carinho vai hoje vai
representar um querendo os meus
problemas
o meu grande problema é não saber disso
não há nada
isso constitui um grande desafio
meu principal desafio é quando dizem que
eu não sou capaz de fazer as coisas com
didi a isso não é pra ti não é
alcançável vista a fazer isso ao pois
então é mesmo aí que eu vou ganhar os
assim atingir mesmo esse nos fazem crime
mais longe nos fazem sejam melhores
tal como jovens e também tem sempre na
da procura os concursos passatempos
programas de empreendedorismo criar e
inovar feliz feliz desportivas feridas
com trabalhos que não são bem trabalhos
seres que não são não sou nada mas é
isso que nos faz crer que o xerez mais
fácil e mais longe
é isso faz com que estavam cumprindo
aquilo que nós somos
pois bem essas pequenas minhas
experiências foram tentando dar a noção
que o até fazer alguma coisa que já até
sei como é que as coisas funcionam então
sim eu sei que funciona assim e sei que
isso pode ser assim porque não
experimentar o contrário e só complica
porque eu chegava à conclusão que
tentava fazer uma
eita tentar conseguir um protocolo nunca
dava certo
ou então dava muito bem mas é isso tem
piada é quando as coisas não andam bem
olhar nos aprender uns corrigir um dia
olhar a tvs aprender corrigir rios
constituinte quanto estúpidos fundos por
ter falhado uma coisa que é tão simples
continuada com essas minhas crianças eu
pensava ver que nós temos tempo a falhar
mas já falhas que nós temos que deixar
como tal e não cheiro mais por exemplo
nós temos a fruta da época é proteger é
porque tem sabor o seu bordel é aquela
obra
agora nesta altura em que nós fizemos
fazer uma reserva ecológica ou frito
cesinha temos frutas como dióspiros
chuvas
os fruticultores castanhas próximo
nessa altura nós até comemos engordamos
pois vivemos do frio e chega o verão
chega o verão temos frutas com mais água
como se tratam o problema é que nós
queremos inverter as coisas
é bom assim até combina com as cores do
natal tem o vermelho que eu verde e azul
são muito práticas provar praia nós
tentamos reverter as situações das
frutas mas não ser sincero o seguro não
é igual há coisas em que nós queremos
acertar outras coisas que mais vai
deixar
mas quando olhamos ou seja uma uma
derrota não significa uma uma não
vitória
ou seja o fato poder usar uma coisa não
significa que não atingimos eu ter
nascido requerem da mãe que foi ar ainda
vai falhar mas porque não era para nós
aquilo não era para nós é continuar
enfrentando como este temos que ver uma
coisa é as grandes inovações são foi da
história de campinas e se não for essas
falhas e aprendizagem gaia ganhos nós
não conseguiríamos a lado nenhum mas
também temos que nos conformar um
pezinho e porque é que eu virei pra
corridas exatamente por isso porque foi
uma receita
então eu fui há cerca de dois anos não
estava aqui tava na bélgica e não tenha
fruta da época não tenha fruta da época
então tive que vir após produtos locais
os produtos locais que eram a cerveja
ver alguém que era o chocolate belga e
fantástico fcm camada de gordura
o que tem mais distante que minha avó
que tem problemas de visão be sobe assim
ainda não tenha sido nada é verdade eu
não tenha mesmo nada então se teme a
volta dos gols teve gordinhos disse
aquilo vai se calhar tem que mudar e que
é uma coisa é aceitar a fórmula do
chocolate
uai fãs e cerveja não funcionou então
tal exercício e dieta pois vai todos os
dias e implantava a cheia também é para
fazer um exercício mas não ficava por
ali mineirinho é de que as aulas antes
do estágio a ele mas se viram que ele
mais longe e arrisca a ir correr oi e
correr com a pai e minha mãe e minha
irmã é todos faziam exercícios
então nós vamos todos dar à nossa volta
tinha eu ia correr 20 minutos no banho
que dizer correr ea gritar ocorrer é
horrível eu ia 20 minute eu ia sofrer
chegava a casa é morrer já não podia
fazer mais já não conseguia mexer provou
parem com isso mas seria aventuraram
seria aventuraram e alguém tinha que
fosse ao cão ok você casa sozinha e fui
uma vez sozinha brutal prodim lima
entretanto conseguiu ficar viotti
ambiente que vi o time tão podia fazer
25 minutos e trinta minutos
passava o tempo fazer uma hora era o
mínimo não sei a casa sem fazer uma hora
e por 100m livre - com aquilo eu ia
vinha e e 22 deles fosse por dia o que
não tem nada a fazer senão tinha mas
livrar de mim mesmo que você me
inscrever em provas e esgotar se
começaram a surgir eo vice e aquela
coisa e vamos e e também vão e nós vamos
também
agora chegou o problema
nós temos que fazer as coisas com algum
objetivo
tivemos objetivo as coisas acabam por
não acontecer
por exemplo nós vamos o ginásio vamos o
ginásio estruturados aqui os exercícios
e nós temos maio ao jazz e fazer isso em
casa para poupar os trotes deixar o
ginásio em que acontece quando deixamos
de exatamente deixou de fazer exercícios
com nossa segunda exatamente o mesmo
ae agora têm por mim piso
não tô anos igor durante uma semana sem
grande duas em vez de planear vista
verde plano livro fantástico é é claro
que isto vai durar muito tempo até pelo
resultado frente e vou continuar a fazer
isso porque tanto tempo
qual é o objetivo a espera para fazer
análises a então me deixando com mais um
então esta semana para fazer análises e
é o pênis não tivemos alguém te
responder isso não tivemos alguém dizer
que estamos a fazer isso não se impôs
mesmo não fazemos e eu e conhecemos
atualmente o mesmo foi o tempo correr em
um anime conseguiu furtar correr então
tenho que fazer um objetivo
ok sofre provas até hoje em 30 bairros
foi uma maratona pois nunca vou fazer
uma maratona não haja vou fazer o melhor
para aquele número tendo por isso é
muito tempo fui treinar se à neto nos
planos de treino está a funcionar
o objetivo é fazer três horas e quinze
mulher vai ser muito ambicioso é pai
melhores com calma não tinha barreira
dos 30 e vai ter um fui andando aqui o
técnico vai haver muita gente não
precisaria passar e ele falar que o
técnico é tão bom tão bom tão bem e
chegou ao fim o povo hoje e tinha duas
horas e 59 ficaram em sexto lugar e os
seus lugares as portuguesas não se
estuda geral das famílias e muito bem
muito bem
ou seja trabalhar com o objetivo fiz
algo e que ainda pequeno trem que ia
fazendo 30 que o grande teste o mês de
maio era uma conquista pequenina mas o
fato de estar todos os dias ao fim o que
eu já fiz aqui vou eu já fiz e flor
quando cheguei a prova já não custou
nada porque eu já estava feito
aqueles objetivos todos os dias e
ajudaram a fazer um uma grande prova
ajudaram a um objetivo maior
mexe isto ok não vou criar uma data não
faz mal comprometa-se com o grupo faça
um grupo corrida vão todos os dias aqui
pouco com eles os puxou pelos outros
hoje o treinador edinho planejem um cão
mas vão façam alguma coisa ae o mínimo
mas correr não é pra mim não faz mal não
ocorrerá existem outros mil transportes
podem praticar é só escolher a lista é
imensa
a amaggi e isso acontece sobretudo nós
cuidarmos de nós sabia da nossa dieta da
nossa alimentação
nossa vai estar tudo acontece nós nós é
que temos de criar os nossos objetivos
temos que responder foram os primeiros
alunos nós não tem que servir nós mas
nós podemos pra outros nós queremos
servir os outros iam que ele também com
o nosso trabalho
ai eu não consigo mandar faça um plano
de crise e as façam façam projetos
comprometa-se clausen
o que é isto é a loucura sim é um
pelinho é um peeling vício é a isso na
primeira da artista chama os malucos chá
- looks
mas aí agora tá chover agora tá frio não
vou correr não fazem exercício não vais
vai va e vapor sitcom mais lamy no cic
mais sujo e felicidade chegar à casa com
com a mateus que vemos é muito melhor
ter ficado em casa no sofá mas vocês vão
sair e voltar três anos a contar da
equipa no trilho e fui um sítio fiquei
cheio do ano a que foi brutal adorei as
nossas experiências e que nós percebemos
que não conseguimos fazer e que no fim
chegamos conseguimos fazemos é muito
melhor a gente por cento casa e custa
pois quando chegamos e não consigo dizer
que 100 quilômetros faça skol brutal por
ficar cinco mil anos a pensar aqui o
significado em casa era só mais um dia
em casa era só mais um dia na minha zona
de conforto
isto é tudo uma questão de rotatividade
porque o que eu faço não é nada de você
dizer porque é um mundo que ela fez
tanto não é que eu faço nada eu olho pra
você só vê as pessoas e eu acho que eu
sou escorrem mais correm muito mais que
eu
duas têm evento esteve entre os muito
maiores que as minhas pessoas fazem
coisas que ele esqueça que existem
pessoas que fazem coisas que nem sequer
penso e uso e os diariamente
eu não faço não sei ainda não fala delas
porque não percebo nada aquilo é tudo
uma questão de uma atividade agora nós
temos que inventar temos que
experimentar
temos que criar temos
as coisas falharam corrigir pinos e
avançar
e esse não podemos nada até a próxima
ó